ANTHONY MAYS: Hi,
I'm Anthony D. Mays--
software engineer at Google.
And I'm here to talk to
you on the topic of one
to more-- why sharing
our narrative matters.
Again, my name is Anthony Mays.
I'm a software engineer at
Google-- just a software
engineer, but I also happen
to be a DEI advocate.
And I think it'd be
interesting to start off
by just talking about
how I became a DEI
advocate in the first place.
I started off my
life as a foster kid
in Compton, after being exposed
to physical and sexual abuse.
And throughout that journey, I
learned how to be a programmer,
and learned how to code
when I was very young.
Began to become very
interested in computer science,
and went to the University
of California, Irvine
to get a degree in that area.
Went throughout my career not
thinking that I was good enough
to reach a place like a Google
or one of the other big tech
companies.
But I always wanted
to work for Google.
And so after failing
the interview process
and then succeeding
on my second try,
I now find myself a Googler.
And it's been the culmination
of a lot of things
and a dream come true for me.
And I didn't anticipate
becoming a DEI advocate.
By the way, DEI stands
for diversity, equity,
and inclusion-- if you
didn't already know.
And these are things that are
very important to me, which
is one of the reasons
why I've become
so passionate about advocating
for more diversity, equity,
and inclusion in tech.
Championing more belonging
in this space that
has traditionally
been challenged
with not having
enough representation
from various individuals.
And so I want to talk to
today about how I do this.
How I advocate for better
DEI through something
that I like to describe
as sharing your narrative.
Now, there's three things
that enables me to do
what I do as a DEI advocate.
First is just having a
strong company culture that
enables me to do what I do.
Second is having the
support and participation
of people from throughout
all levels of the company.
That's been very
important for me,
as others have championed
and supported me in my work.
And then, lastly, this idea
of sharing your narrative.
So I'm just going to break each
of these down to be more clear.
So when we talk about having
an empowering culture,
there's really four things
that I think work well
about the culture at Google.
First of all, the culture
is strong and well-defined.
There's things that make
Google's culture unique.
The people that we hire
tend to be very intelligent.
Tend to be quirky.
We describe it as
googliness Googliness
is a description of the
culture that we seek to have.
One where innovation
is encouraged.
Where people work hard, but
are also able to collaborate.
A culture where you can have
fun and enjoy what you do,
but at the same time, tackle
very deep and hard and meaty
problems.
And that kind of culture
is well-suited for someone
who is working in the DEI
space because there are so
many challenges.
There's a lot of
obstacles to overcome.
And having a culture that
champions and supports
the best and brightest
is important.
As part of that, trust in
leadership is important.
And I don't mean managers
and managers of managers.
What I mean is leaders.
People who are naturally
inclined to find a problem,
and see it, and
want to tackle it.
You want to find people
who can be leaders,
even if they don't have the
formal title-- as I don't.
You want to support
them in leadership.
And it's important that
when you find leaders
that you trust them to be
leaders and support them
in their journey.
One of the other things that's
important about Google's
culture is the
emphasis on results.
So it's not just about
saying cool things.
It's about doing cool things.
And as a DEI advocate, one of
the things that is important
is that I'm held accountable for
showing the results of the work
that I do.
And making sure that we're
moving in the right direction.
Measuring results
is important, too.
So having regular surveys
that gauge employee sentiment,
and really understanding how
people are thinking and feeling
is a very important part of
ensuring that the culture
remains strong.
And then last, but not least,
there are enablement tools.
And in order to
be a DEI advocate,
there are a lot of
tools that I need.
Everything from scheduling
and calendering,
to social media tools, to
templates, to program guides.
You name it, there's a lot of
tools that are used in the work
that I do to help
me be effective.
And it's important to have
quick and ready access
to those tools.
Oftentimes, I'm not needing
to ask for permission
to use these tools.
I'm just encouraged to use them,
and to use them responsibly.
And having that kind
of freedom enables
me to be very effective
as a DEI advocate.
Now in addition to the
culture, another thing
that's very important
is making sure
that everyone is
helping to drive change.
You know, a culture it's not
just up to one or two people
to decide how that
culture is going to be.
Every time you add a new
person to the company,
every time you add in the
person of the culture,
it impacts the culture.
And it's important that
everyone understands
that they have a role and
place in this discussion
and in this change.
It's not just up
to black people--
such as myself, for instance.
And when you don't have a
culture in which everyone feels
encouraged and
empowered to participate
it places the burden on those
who really seek and desire,
maybe even need
change to do the work.
And that's not healthy.
One of the challenges
of being me--
being a person who happens
to identify as a black man
and as a Christian-- is that
there aren't that many of me
in tech.
At least, not yet.
And it's unfair to place
all of the burden on change
on the people who are
the least represented
or who aren't well-represented.
Furthermore, it's
important for everyone
to understand why you
want more representation.
Why you want more
inclusiveness and belonging.
So that everyone can
buy into the same vision
going in the same direction.
Now, one of the
things that I believe
is very important towards
helping us achieve this goal is
the idea of the narrative.
And it used to be called
diversity narrative.
You can call it that
or belonging narrative.
However it is.
But the idea of the narrative
is that it is a story that
fleshes out who you are.
It really fleshes out
not just who you are,
but why you care about
diversity, equity,
and inclusion.
And I would like to think
that the narrative reflects
the things that don't
show up on your resume.
A lot of us have skills
and qualifications
that we know make us suitable
for executing the business
tasks that we are
assigned to execute.
But there are other
things that inform
how we are the way that we are.
These are attributes
and qualities
that we gain over
our lifetime that
inform the technical
aspects of what we do.
And it's really about, as
Martin Luther King said once,
the content of your character.
And we want to have a
good understanding of how
our character is shaped
the way that it is,
and how it is that we
relate to other people.
And how the differences
that we bring,
most importantly, inform
how we make decisions,
whether in a team
or on a project,
so that we're able to
build one another up.
And this is really
about making sure
that we've got a
culture of belonging.
Where everyone feels like they
have a part in the discussion.
have a part and a role to play.
And that they feel like they're
part of the team in helping
to achieve the right results.
In today's climate, where you
have such underrepresentation,
it's common for
people like me who
come from a
nontraditional background
to sometimes feel
excluded or to not feel
like we belong as we should.
And I've talked
to many people who
have had that narrative
over the years, whether it's
a woman who's a
software engineer,
but is treated as though
she's a project manager.
Or whether it's a black
person who is misidentified.
Or any of those other things.
Those kinds of interactions
cause people to not
feel like they belong,
and as a result of that,
sometimes when we chase
diversity before inclusion,
we end up making this
revolving door effect.
Where the people from diverse
backgrounds that we hire
end up walking right
back out the door
because they don't
feel like they're
part of the organization.
And so narratives can help build
more representation and more
belonging, more specifically,
within the organization
so that people who are hired
and new talent that comes along
know that they are part
of the organization.
That they're part of the team.
And that they belong and
can do productive work.
And so one of the
things that I think
I do more than anything
else as a DEI advocate
is to empower other people
to share their narrative.
To open up about
what makes them them.
And how they contribute to
the culture and to the team
and to doing the things that
they do in a more holistic way.
And so, this is what brings
me to a special initiative
that I started within Google,
and I'd like to share with you.
Because I think you
may be wondering, well,
how do you share your narrative?
How do you encourage
other people
to share their narrative, and
to talk about who they are,
and what they
bring to the table,
and why DEI matters to them?
I think that once
you understand how
to encourage other
people to do that,
it can have a very powerful and
transformative effect, as we'll
talk about shortly.
So I started the thing
called Share Your Narrative
within Google.
And what it does is it provides
a platform and a framework
and a space for people to
talk about their narratives.
And I think that it's
one of those things that
really helps to scale my
impact as a DEI advocate.
Because I'm just
one person, and I
want to have as much impact as
widespread as possible while
I'm sitting in my seat.
And I believe that the Share
Your Narrative initiative
has helped me to do that.
As I mentioned before, the
Share Your Narrative initiative
really is three components.
One is a platform
that is built and used
in order to encourage
people to, first of all,
understand what a narrative is,
and then, two, how to share it.
Two, there's a framework.
And so there's specific things
that make up a good narrative,
and we talk about that
And then, lastly, we
provide an environment
where you can explore
what that narrative is, and
understand how it works,
and how you can improve
it and make it better.
So first thing, the platform.
When I built the Share
Your Narrative site,
it was very simple.
It was just a Google Sites site.
And it linked to a
Google+ community,
which is now Google Currents.
And that's really all I needed.
Google Currents was
great for providing
a place where folks could
post video, articles, images.
As they're sharing a
story from their life,
they're able to show a
picture of maybe that time
of their life to
help folks visualize
what's going on or maybe
pointing to a helpful video.
Having rich multimedia on
a social media platform
is very important
for helping people
to really share
parts of themselves
that maybe they
wouldn't otherwise
share if they didn't have
that kind of a platform.
On the website that we have
for Share Your Narrative,
it's just a static page.
It includes some
instructions and FAQ.
Really very simple, but
it's an one-stop shop
for finding out what a narrative
is and how to share it.
And at Google, we make it
very easy to share websites.
We have special links.
And so I crafted a special
link that points to the site
and made it very easy and
memorable for people to get to.
Next comes the framework.
And I'll admit that I didn't
invent the diversity narrative
framework, but more
than hardly use it.
Now a diversity narrative
really is formed of three parts.
First, there is the reason
why you care about DEI.
And so you talk about,
what are the things that
are meaningful to you about
improving representation
or more belonging
or those things,
and you'll just briefly
touch on that theme.
And the theme will set up
for the second part, which
is a story that
helps illustrate why
you care about that aspect
of diversity, equity,
and inclusion.
It should be something real,
something that happened.
It can be something that
relates to a business situation
that you've
encountered, where you
saw an optimal result achieved
because of DEI or the opposite,
if the lack of representation
didn't result in the outcome
that you were hoping for.
So there's that story.
And if there isn't a story that
you feel comfortable sharing
about yourself, perhaps
there's something
that you've noticed in another
situation that didn't directly
happen to you that
made you think
about why DEI is important.
Certainly, the events
pertaining to George Floyd
has caused many to not
just hear about, but also
see some of the reasons
why this work is
important and impactful.
And so you can talk about that
in your narrative and share,
maybe, a moment from
your life where it really
hit home for you.
And then, the last
thing that I'll
talk about in the framework
is a call to action.
So you'll have the purpose--
why DEI matters to you.
You'll have the story that
connects to that purpose.
And then, lastly,
some call to action.
And the call to action
is super important.
In the call to action,
you want to make sure
that you're inviting people
to join you in the work.
Because hopefully,
in parts one and two,
you've inspired people to
understand why they, too,
should care about DEI.
And if they're ready to
act, you can provide them
a way to join you in the work.
The last thing that the Share
Your Narrative community does
is provide a safe
environment for people
to share their narrative
and to feel supported.
And so it manifests in two ways.
Number one, there's
someone who reviews
the narratives for
spelling and grammar
and just to make
sure that things
are cohesive and succinct.
Then once someone decides to
post within the Google Currents
community, other people can
like on those narratives
or share their
comments or support
the people who are writing.
And from what I've seen,
it's always been positive.
It's always been good when
people post these narratives
and are able to say,
hey, I connect with that.
One of the other unique things
about specifically using
Google Currents is
that in our community
we're able to sort posts by a
number of different factors.
And so if you were
writing a post that
focused on why age
representation matters,
you could categorize
your post that way.
Or if you're talking
about race or gender,
you could categorize those.
And then it gives the
community a great way
to be able to see the narratives
from these various axes
of diversity that
one may care about.
Now our community
is rather small.
It's just 156 community
members and growing.
And I'd say that's not bad
for a software engineer.
But if those numbers
seem small, I
want you to think about
the multiplicative effect
of sharing your narrative.
See, a narrative isn't just
shared within our community.
Oftentimes, it can be
included in an email link.
It can be shared
during a team meeting.
It can be spoken in an offsite.
Used during a speech before a
very technical presentation.
There's any number of
ways that you can do that.
Even just sharing with
your own family or friends.
By sharing your narrative,
you connect with other people
and help them to understand
why it matters to you.
And if they care
about you, why it
should matter to them, as well.
And so, the narrative has
a multiplicative effect.
My own story about my journey
to Google from Compton
was featured in a BuzzFeed video
that had over 5 million views.
And certainly, it's
probably safe to say
that hundreds of thousands of
people all around the world
have heard my story
and narrative,
and have been encouraged
by my journey,
as I've given of myself
to talk about how it is
that I came to be in the space.
And how I encourage other
people to do the same.
And so there is this
multiplicative effect of each
and every single one
of those individuals.
Some of who are
engineers, like myself.
Others are executives,
some are in sales.
They come from all
different parts of Google
and all around the
world, and they
participate in this community.
And also share their
own narratives in places
that we may not be able to see.
And so there's a
great positive benefit
of being able to see
these narratives grow
and be shared widely.
This really is
about scalability.
There's only so much that
I can do as an individual.
But I want to make sure that I
can empower the next generation
to do what I'm doing and to
do it even better so that we
can encourage more inclusiveness
and belonging in the space.
Now I just want to end with
a couple of final thoughts
that I think are important.
First of all, understand
that knowledge isn't power.
Not knowledge by itself.
Knowledge rightly
applied is powerful.
And that's really
what this is about.
A lot of us have been learning
over the past few months
about why the conversations
about race, about inclusion,
about belonging--
not just the tech,
but in the world--
why these things matter.
It's not enough just to
sit on that knowledge
and not do anything.
It's important to do something.
And sharing your
narrative can be
one of the easiest ways for
you to be impactful in terms
of inviting other people
to the conversation,
inviting other
people to the work.
Now even though it's
one of the easiest ways,
it's still not easy.
And I know that it takes you
sharing a bit of yourself
that maybe you didn't plan on
sharing at work, and that's OK.
You're not alone.
And one of the best
things about the Share
Your Narrative program is
that it has shown people
that they're not alone.
I'm not alone as a
person who has struggled
through a rough upbringing
to become a software
engineer, beating the odds.
There are other people
like me across all
different backgrounds
and all different shades.
And that's really what
belonging is all about.
At the end of the
day, I know that,
as a result of this
program and other things,
that I belong just as
much as anyone else,
because I'm a Googler.
And so, I hope that this time
has been encouraging to you.
Thank you for tuning in to
watch this presentation.
And the best of
luck to you as you
pursue greater
diversity, equity,
and inclusion in your
company or organization.
Thank you.